being known for something in the game
you play
can be a badge of honor justin keeps it
alive
wasn't there bouncing into the corner
energy still around
justin is there by the shot
but depending on what that trademark is
it can also
very easily become a blight on an
otherwise
promising career drakken now still
holding off backside of banana crush
wants to work in that direction
and oh my goodness 30 degree window
dragon
how did that miss and in league of
legends
a game that picks up and drops metas
every couple of months
the inability to adapt can have brutal
consequences
faker has never lost
with leblanc on the competitive stage sk
telecom t1 are wiped the nexus turrets
are going down lpl's edward gaming
are the 2015 mid-season invitational
champions
however when it comes to true
stubbornness
and inflexibility you'll struggle to
find a better example
than constantino's napoleon forgiven
sortsu
a turret-destroying lane terrorizing
aidy cary fueled by an endless supply
of confidence do you feel right now that
you have the most skill in all the
bottom lanes
by far by far all right a controversial
and abrasive figure whose
talent was only exceeded by his
unbending ego
back then forgiven was so far ahead of
the metagame
and was this game-changing figure that
he was
legitimately worth it and now amazing's
in trouble he's taking another tower
but he gets away with the safeguard oh
from downtown forgiven uses the rocket
straight on the towers
but it hasn't come without a cost all in
all he was a for sure a really good
player
would i consider playing with him again
no you know if you ever pick him up
it just sets such a bad message out to
any of the other players that you want
to pick up
this guy whose way of thinking doesn't
align with anyone else in professional
league of legends right now so will we
ever see the return of europe's
dominating bot lane conqueror or has his
arrogance squashed his career
once and for all i still have a belief
that he can be one of the best in the
world again
[Music]
now if you're not familiar with the man
who is by
far europe's most polarizing ad carry
you're in for a treat you see forgiven
is a passionate motivational speaker
guys remember this is the start of a
journey we play like we're playing
scrims that's the most basic thing
yeah we live and die by this word
and he's also a master of impersonation
[Music]
[Applause]
but on top of his obvious gift for
mimicry
forgiven is a staunch defender of the
follicly impaired
can't wait for the god-given verses
umajan battle the hairlines
why do people always mock people without
hair i do not understand
we're prettier and far more confident
anyway back in 2013 when his dome had a
little bit less sheen
forgiven burst onto the european league
scene with the copenhagen wolves and it
was with that roster that he established
himself
as a new breed of carrie a
hyper-aggressive mechanically talented
player
who didn't shy away from a fight and
again survives the regen comes in he
finally goes down
forgiven though he's got two members on
him but he's just kiting them around
they're supportive and liberty comes in
and it's a double kill for forgiveness
we showed himself
both able and crucially eager to
actually carry games
and make his lane the focal point then
they're rejecting it back up and going
in
flash tip as well get them right into
there but jankos kicked straight away
from that one and the wolves are ripping
them to pieces here
two kills already both of them for
forgiven and he continues to
there's the fall can he get the penta he
flashes in for it
and there is the penta kill coming down
for forgiven
over time as his reputation grew in game
fans began to realize that forgiven's
attention-grabbing playstyle was merely
an extension of the man himself
do you feel right now that you have the
most skill in all the bottom lanes
by far by far all right to forgiven it
didn't matter how
others perceived him he only cared about
what he thought about himself
and ultimately that's what instantly
turned him into a star in a
family-friendly scene made up of polite
soft-spoken baby faces he was a breath
of fresh air
we had so many problems in our team but
were piling up like
nobody gave a set about how to improve
them and what should happen in the team
and how we should be a good european
health system not a team that would end
up in
sixth seventh eighth place nobody gives
a [ __ ] about these teams right like
who cares you see forgiven firmly
believed that his way
was the best way and to his credit in
the early part of his career
nobody was proving him wrong and spencer
now on the frederick he might end up
dying yeah i think he's going to gets
the dunk off and
we'll give it a point for giving whoa my
goodness
did he make the outplay rydel still on
the chase but and rated his body
blocking it he's going to go
down forgiven with the double forgiven
no flash available he dashes forwards
steel back gets the shield up and red is
coming out going up
we do see collateral and buckshot is
going to be available summon a kill
comes up that's a double stun and
rachet's got them forgiven kill cap
two kills sk are on the board a serious
amount of damage on him is forgiven
moves forward fox
trying to sustain up yarning now there's
the exhaust not forgiven order comes in
and picks up fox there's a shutdown
however by end rated as he takes over 18
down forgiven flashing forward
gets another fix up cassini the most
valuable player
of the european spring split by
far there's no denying that historically
forgiven was probably the single most
influential
uh player ever to play ad carry in the
west um
maybe even overall he was our equivalent
of uzi in the sense that he
broke a lot of pre-existing rules that
we had
for what the ad carrier was supposed to
be and he had a very strong
understanding of how the supports should
be interacting with the ad carrier
laning phase etc and as a result
forgiven had a level of lane dominance
that other ad carries
weren't even attempting to have so this
was a massive game changer
by spring of 2015 forgiven had
established himself as the crown-bearing
conqueror of europe's bottling his
talent for creating
flashy highlights even led to
comparisons being made between
him and mechanically gifted superstars
from other regions
but these sorts of parallels only fed
his ego and as much as his self-belief
was the source of his early individual
success
even back then it was a serious cause
for his teammate's concern
probably the most interesting thing
about forgiven is the only flaw he has
as a player
is his temperament and who he is as a
person because normally
you can say about 80 carries like oh
yeah the skill is really good or like
you know they're really good in blind
but not in team fights oh they're really
good in team fights but not as good
he is good in all facets of being an
eddie carrie
except that he's a bit of an [ __ ]
sometimes as a teammate
that wasn't forgiven's only vice though
you see even when he wasn't serving
suspensions for
unsavory conduct his biggest problem
was his inflexibility in game forgiven's
trademark was to go
ham in lane force out his opponent and
take down their turrets as
fast as he possibly could playing any
other way was
simply out of the question even if it
meant putting his team at a disadvantage
why because he never felt he was at a
disadvantage
he was just that sure of himself when i
play the game
i like to stomp my enemy i mean as i
said multiple times in lane fights no
matter what the comp is
on both things i don't play winning
claims just to win them
i play links to win them just by
sounding good challenging myself like in
a way
and i don't think many people can win
against me in europe and
i think it has been proven now just
because forgiven wasn't interested in
changing with the times didn't mean that
league of legends was gonna stand still
even though he found himself alongside
stronger individual players in h2k
later in 2015 forgiven couldn't win
games by himself
the same way he did in the spring and
for an expressive
outplay artist who shone in the
spotlight having to surrender its warmth
made him increasingly combative well it
was like
so difficult for him to learn stuff
because if you
point out his mistake he would like
explode and he would be
really nega like not negative because he
was very passionate about the game so
that
caused him this way but it was really
difficult to talk to him we tried to do
it
as like players but also as like you
know the coach and it was like so
difficult to handle him but it appeared
as though h2k
wouldn't have to walk on eggshells much
longer as relief from their tyrannical
greek bot laner came in the form of an
envelope today i woke up and i
got a letter from the creek army but
i have to go to my army duty at even
march so
so this means but i
maybe lose a normal season again and
the playoffs and some speed because it's
a
nine months duration so tomorrow
it may be my my last game it's just for
at least a year so i am sad but
in the end i'm grateful for for what i
did
so the community was moved by seeing
europe's
greatest antagonist fighting back tears
at the prospect of having to leave the
competitive scene
but fortunately for forgiven he was able
to defer his military service and finish
the remainder of spring with h2k
before joining origen for the summer and
after the team's poor start to the split
he was benched citing a lack of
motivation
forgiven wouldn't be on the sidelines
for long though since
strangely he ended up back on h2k for
the remainder of the summer split
with h2k forgiven was granted the
freedom to play to his strengths
and while he was happy that didn't mean
everyone was
since we didn't play as much around bot
lane with frieze
we had to play on bottling with forgiven
because with forgiveness that he would
have the same play style and he wouldn't
change it so no matter what kind of
draft you would make you would always
have to be
aware that your button is going to like
kind of push and try to punish your
opponent but miraculously in spite of
forgiven's rigidity
h2k somehow made it work the team was
able to put together an impressive split
and
cement themselves as europe's third seed
at worlds later that year
finally for the first time in his career
forgive and have the opportunity to
prove himself on league's
biggest stage and it was an opportunity
he didn't want to waste
and now mountains getting fired down
this is such a tense fight it goes on as
you can see
over time h2k and triumph they got one
kill on the port and they keep on
chasing
looking for on flash root he's gonna go
out of it and he's got no more spell
shield
forgiven with the pickup but mouse his
ga is gonna get popped vander a little
bit too low in this one it is just he
stole it from what the steal
away yanko secures a absolutely
massive elder drake and edg are
evaporating
on the spot it's good bye binko goodbye
everybody
and how you gotta think that is good by
game they have the targets they need in
their eyes oh
doing damage with the stars
and forgiveness coming up huge those are
two kills from pawn
he's gonna push up
he spawns into it forgiven's the last
one left
miko's there to do what he can but it's
so mismatched it probably won't be it
forgiven alive the triple kill for
forgiven
and it looks like h2k will seal the deal
your first seed from group c going to
the quarterfinals
how's that for your legacy even though
the semi-finals would be as far as
h2k's world's run would go the team and
forgiven emerged as
heroes for their region but that career
defining
high was very short-lived in 2017 he
relocated to greece
and played in the lgc and eu masters
before finally kickstarting his military
service in 2018.
in his absence european league of
legends continued to flourish on the
world stage
new superstars emerged and the game
continued to evolve
but all the while a small contingent of
fans began to wonder
if god given would ever return to claim
his crown
and in april of 2019 they finally got
their answer
did you miss me that's right forgiven
had re-emerged from the ether but not
just that
he claimed to be a changed man no
i'm going to be like more lenient with
people people and in general i'm going
to be more of a nice guy or like
it's actually surreal to say that but
it's how liga is right now it's
it's it's it's ecosystem but forces this
kind of and
even if you either adapt or you die it's
pretty much it it's safe to say that
this more aerodynamic
supposedly reworked forgiven drew
immediate skepticism but in spite of the
naysayers there were those who
still believed he could return to his
previous heights
he's playing like legit 13 to 14 games a
day like anybody who is looking for a
dedicated ad carry
and who is worried about whether or not
forgiven is the kind of guy who is like
talented but lazy
can look at this and see that this is a
guy that clearly is going to put the
effort in to get back at the level
that we all know that forgiven can be at
not long after announcing his free
agency
forgiven secured a starting spot on fc
schalke where he'd have the chance to
show the world that he was still
relevant
and truly reformed and in the spring of
2020
fans would finally get to see the
triumphant return of the region's
legendary controversial superstar but
unfortunately for forgiven his return
was anything but
triumphant shulker's split got off to a
rocky start with the team losing
6 games on the bounce and that's all it
took for someone as
fiercely competitive as forgiven to
revert back to his past behavior
in one signature brutal tweet he
vocalized his frustration by throwing
his
team under the bus once again forgiven
had proven himself to be his
own worst enemy and schalke's response
to his
self-benching was to let him rot there
for the rest of the calendar year
the amount of people that he let down
was insane to be honest like a lot of us
put our stocks and forgiven
not just because we believed in him but
because we believed he deserved it
because he had gone through
so much he didn't come from like a very
privileged background at all he was
providing for his family while he was
doing all of this
and he got dragged into the military in
greece and had to take a ton of time off
from this when he had just reached his
peak
and when he did get his chance again and
when we figured he was taking it
he was very very willing to just throw
it away
it didn't matter how much natural talent
he had how passionate he was about the
game
or how much he'd grown and matured
through life experience
after all this time he was still a
shitty teammate
and while that may have been swept under
the rug years before
it wasn't going to fly today i don't see
a world where there are players that
want to play together with forgiven i
don't see a world where coaches want to
work
with the perception that the community
has forgiven
the greatest tragedy for forgiven is
that he'll likely
never get another chance to realize the
potential that he
teased throughout his career and it's
all because of the ego that he
simply couldn't check at the door the
same ego which made him
such a spectacular player to watch in
the first place
big focus for giving an athena up on the
side and athena has lost that 1v1 well
intruding forgiven doing some serious
work now yankovic's going forward
forgiven getting it done
another rocket jump he's looking for
lokin he wants to get that finish off
it's a triple kill for forgiven
and he wants another one loki may not
give it to him though oh there it is the
quattro kill
look there's no denying that forgiven
has been the architect of his own
downfall over the years but we shouldn't
have sympathy for the path that he chose
because at the end of the day he
wouldn't want it forgiven might have
written the book on how
not to behave as an esports professional
but that's not the only mark he's left
on the game
during the course of his tumultuous
career he redefined
the role of 80 carries in europe setting
a standard for his contemporaries to aim
for
and surpass and let's be honest as toxic
and volatile as he's shown himself to be
there's also something admirable about
forgiven it's not every day that you
find a competitor who is
so passionate about their own
convictions that they're willing to let
it turn them into the villain of their
own story the legacy of forgiven
was always a promise it was never really
a story of one of the best players you
could ever had it was a story of a
player who would one day
prove that he was one of the best
players that you have ever had
and the moment that he decided to drop
it all he
broke that promise and now he will
always just be a big
what if and that is a massive tragedy
because this guy was undeniably ahead of
everyone when he came on the scene
and he never became the world champion
he never pushed us through to the finals
he never took europe to the next level
like he took the ad carry role
and he never took himself there either
forgiven might be an
ass he might be a misunderstood genius
and he might be a parable about wasted
potential but whether you like him or
not
that's who he chooses to be and in a
strange way
you have to respect it some people come
to win some people can actually
manipulate their feelings their emotions
some people can't not everyone can be a
role model
not everyone wants to be and not
everyone fits this
this guy as a player he was [ __ ] hell
of fun to watch
because he was so he played for himself
like
he just he's just like i'm playing for
the highlights oh i mean it's like it's
like
he's not so much like that anymore but
it's like simple back in the day like
when he was just a real [ __ ] w
selfish w warrior like literally dude
yeah he just did such
stupid [ __ ] and like he was so [ __ ]
sick to watch like
oh yeah i love i love players like that
love like terrible team players but like
super fun
super fun to watch